j'ai dressé les clowns des acrobates les
gens du voyage ah ah ça me rappelle des
souvenirs que je voudrais avoir aidé
amour que je n'ai pas connu à tant rêver
j'ai gâché mes vins berges la gamberge
la gamberge un très chouette le gars qui
chantait ça l'autre soir au cabaret mais
mais ma parole c'est lui comment
s'appelle-t-il chan yan ces gens
viennent et lui prend décidément il n'y
a qu'à demander pour être servi
pour en revenir à ce que je disais avant
les vacances je voudrais vous chanter
une chanson qui remonte aux sources
c'est à dire une chanson inspirée par le
folklore le folklore est une des bases
fondamentales de la chanson humanitaire
et sociale et je trouve bien triste
qu'ils ne soient pas mieux considérer
qu'il n'est en effet le folklore est
généralement bien considérer mais
uniquement dans son pays d'origine ce
qui fait que si l'on prend pour exemple
une chanson anglaise comme le god save
the king
on constate que c'est une chanson qui a
un énorme succès en angleterre mais qui
en france n'a presque pas de succès du
tout sauf de temps en temps à l'occasion
de certaines réunions sportives et
encore faut-il que ce jour-là il y ait
des anglais sur le terrain je trouve ça
infiniment dommage et c'est pour
redonner ses lettres de noblesse au
folklore que j'ai voulu m'inspirer des
thèmes folkloriques du gabon pour écrire
une chanson en contre point que j'ai
dédié au docteur chouette there et que
j'ai intitulé le mambo du légionnaire
m
ce pianiste et matignon a fort à aller
cheminée dignement vont jouer pour
oublier cette tournée le cattani
longtemps
danseuse exceptionnellement belle avec
th sensationnel mantel ont été sous le
thème hague a dansé dansé ou c'est la
cata simon hughes blessure une une qui
collait le sable car à quoi l'oeil sur
lignes allaient rouler sur les paliers
qui pend chez leur tronc qui ce décès
celle ci romo sauf un chef zen des
ricochets 1 quand le vent soufflait qui
l'attend feront souffler l'on n'avait
pas de roeulx lez les sources se
camoufler le désert c'est un des sous le
bruit grächen beaucoup des coups de
tonnerre qui gronde des camps les c'est
clair descendez le soleil dardait ses
rayons sur les doigts des moustiques
cavalcade f comme des farfadets des
chameliers qui paraissaient les cheveux
se hérissaient écart de vente s'adresse
à des mirages et qui plus est ceux qui
voudraient que lorsque l'on ne pouvait
plus marcher si l'on a fait mal aux
pieds on en crever car le sable faisait
des tombes à ceux qui décèdent des dans
ce curieux bled où dès le matin
entendait
mambo jura piano système à tignes mans
phone
un légionnaire est né à tignes mambo de
hou échoué pour oublier cette ou rang le
cat 1 qui l'attend il a dans ce secteur
yann et le mans bel effet que d en chine
ans à sillonner le mans telle qu'on
aurait dit
un souffle aux tags à danser danser sous
le ciel du sahara gags désopilants ou
sarasar samatan que les mousses mais les
légionnaires au sahara sarah sarah
pourront faire des fugues et et toc
examinateurs c'est pas un métier ils
veulent tous avoir leur permis se donne
même pas la peine d'apprendre le code de
la rue enfin avec moi pas question de
passe droit premier candidat
bonjour monsieur
asseyez-vous bonjour monsieur monsieur
vous vous trouvez sur une route à grande
circulation n'est ce pas vous croisez
une route départementale dont la largeur
et double de celle d'un chemin vicinal
qui la prolonge au sud-ouest d'une ligne
médiane tracé par le bas côté d'une
route secondaire parallèle à celle comme
et d'éviter en empruntant le trajet
inverse de celui inscrit sur un panneau
indicateur placé derrière il pleut votre
essuie-glaces tombe en panne que feydeau
mais je vous ai posé une question
précise monsieur je vous prie de
répondre oui bon vous ne savez pas et
bien vous viendrait d'en prendre
je suis ok merci beaucoup oui c'est
dégagé parce qu'il ya d'autres candidats
oui c'est ça
niva candidats suivants suivant
poussez pas pages web et l'homme
asseyez-vous notant qu'on affirme
entendre l'examen dont l'un sur les
animaux quand même
vous êtes bien installé ça va comme vous
voulez ben ça me gêne un peu les genoux
harry lui c'est une petite voiture wifi
chez des gros genou j'avais les genoux
la prochaine fois en prendre un autocar
il ya très peu ce que changerait pour
mes genoux bon monsieur première
question vous montez dans votre voiture
celle-ci ne veut pas démarrer que fait
tout ce que je veux ah bah vous feriez
bien le savoir vous montez dans votre
voiture elle ne démarre quoi qu'est ce
que vous faites
eh ben je descends ah oui la manivelle
d'ange des sens puisqu'il un grand coup
de pompe dans cette saloperie de daniel
bien près joue là le capot ch - clé à
molette il classe les moteurs à milmort
soja prades jacob mais je suis pas du
genre à mes s'emmerder part état de fait
rien et puis pas par autre chose non
plus d'ailleurs
suis-je assez clair
bon autre chose me suivre et à présent
vous arrivez à un carrefour
un agent de la force publique vous fait
signe de vous arrêter
qu'est ce que vous faites je pense
tu vas passer le budget rôle sur le
buffet et au passage où un poids qui
régit balance un bon coup de pompe dans
la toile même occasion monsieur s'est
pas appliqué à faire la loi aidera
prenez pour tous le siège
bon maintenant vous êtes sur une route
départementale en bas ça m'étonnerait
qu'est ce que vous dites j ça
m'étonnerait que choisit sur une route
départementale et j'y vais jamais sur
les routes départementales
j'ai plein de boue et ça sent mauvais
mais j'entends bien monsieur mais c'est
une supposition vous êtes sur une route
départementale
non
je suis pas sur une route départementale
je viens de vous dire que j'ai maté
jamais les pieds sur les routes
départementales
j'aime pas ça les routes départementales
jeu et les routes départementales les
routes départementales rien actuellement
cause et ça me donne envie d'envoyer les
mandats dans la conscience claire me
mets un admettra way
les femmes musulmanes car c'est bien la
fille d'asticots à à méru cei vous
commencé à m'énerver avec vos questions
est-ce que je vous en pose des questions
bref je vous en ai ce que je vous
demande qu'est ce que vous faites is pas
ceux ci qu'est ce que vous faites ici
pas cela du tout est-ce que je vous
oblige à l'est sur notre départementale
des pêcheurs est précieuse me demande
pourquoi vous avez cette tête d'abruti
ouais pourquoi ça que la bride les viêt
ont germé 1
la seule chose que je demande c'est si
vous me donnez mon père mais oui ou non
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comme temps
formalité
savate un départ de la 4e étape du
premier tour d'europe aux cyclistes au
yen à waterloo
étape 3 198 km et à 286 km déjà quatre
hommes se sont échappés
la cena ont pas quoi ton bidons etc le
le parc automobile en quoi j'ai soif
n'est que le ce que dit vous êtes tous
les mêmes voulez pas vous charge au
départ et après 50 km où taper les papin
province quoi pasquato bisons en passe
lui voit ses palmes en conflent chaud et
les engrais aux fins
combien de minutes qui sort les anglais
unis ne tient au dernier pointage
quarante secondes est grave pour mettre
le paquet cambronne fighting fantasy
oui les maranges fait le forcing h 30
tarots non inscrivant les coups pleuvent
en fait le boulot on saisit elle arrive
à l'étape frais comme un gardon
excuse moi alors à lui le maillot jaune
à lui les 24 heures à l'huile et biblis
à lui les photos par une bonne voie
quand on prend 8 buts on comprendra
alors ferme là les pédales mais il faut
rien dans l'école mais sur le plat pour
se répartir et forcément ils sont sourds
entre année cette activité toute l'année
bref pas de quoi trop évident que
parfois combinant coin grâce à la comme
ça parce qu'ils tombent ils ont choisi
on a les engrais derrière on c'est vrai
ils ont plein d'astuces et wynton tuner
ramène les [ __ ] ils nous rattrape
oh mais on les prend la pause on peut
les avoir commandé non on peut pas
partir sur les hordes de talleyrand
aujourd'hui bas-rhin moi j'en ai marre
des directeurs sportifs un éloge ton
espagnol en fin de course et il faut
attendre leur permission alors qu'on a
la victoire dans l'open napo n'approche
pas dit qu'on peut se les rattraper les
anglais enfin la pause n'avait jamais vu
constate pas de parler d'envié chez nous
quoi
à combien
un terreau l'eau ainsi l'eau mais bon
bah tant pis pour talleyrand on fonce la
vidange du rheu
encore un petit effort ou alors dans sa
tenue senna pense moi ton bidon
tu dois être au mur à ça va être coupé
les pattes tombe bien on est maintenant
on a bien deux minutes sur 301 on croise
moins d'impôts on devrait pousser la
tactique c'est moi laissez moi faire on
peut pas partir à 4 il faut qu'on se
regroupe on ira où sont les autres
marceau il est temps que il a cassé son
guidon et grossit doigt dans le peloton
ça bagarre cei qu'aujourd'hui un plus
qu'un kilomètre avant waterloo et si on
est parfois on a la victoire facile
alors écoutez moi les filles arriver à
waterloo
vous mettez en corée vous faites le mur
et moi je vous lâche à 200 mètres de la
ligne bandol mais primo alors si je
gagne au waterloo on se farcit le
classement par équipe vous serez bien
content je ne compte pas mes gonds selon
les mots bien avant le maillot de temps
en temps mais rien qu'une fois tiens
peux pas me permettre de prendre des
risques
j'ai encore le tour de l'île d'elbe
alphare cirque plus les six jours de
wagram et critérium de la bérézina des
fous je remporte le tout si je veux
avoir le championnat d'europe par points
alors rien à dire
senna parfois combi dont j'ai le coup de
pompe à écran ça y est les gars waterloo
on n'arrive plus à passer notre monnaie
maillot bombay comme passé sa roue et
mentougou ci alors c'est pas couché
c'était ma pression c'est plus chères
mais plus sûres et plus saines
ici à vélo municipale de waterloo dans
ce plan des d'assistance rapport d'
enquête nous en sommes à se juger
l'arrivée de cete 4e étape du tour
d'europe cycliste mais voici les
coureurs à l'entrée du vélodrome en d2
album me plais au plus un air suivi de
bout en bout de mur à timmins sida et
celles au départ du sprint avant le tour
final de d2 plus cher
après alès mais toi tu pédales en
danseuse d'ailleurs appelé ont fait fort
si la stib merveilleux vous le
connaissez je peux remonter c'est le
pognon des années terribles celle d'abou
les eaux du sacre la souplesse dans les
jambes cette noble mais voici la
nouvelle scène cheikh jaber bassim
jamais changé d'approché passer le mur à
mes jambes je vous rappelle qu'on plante
d'arriver premier plus cher deuxième
napoléon troisième passe hélas murat et
cambronne
vite vite vite plus cher pour la
télévision lui surpris les plus sûres
on a fait ce qu'on a vu napo on a mis le
paquet était en pleine forme
t'en fais pas à mon mieux pas gagnera
d'autres termes à waterloo enfin les
âges non c'est pas un dessin merci les
gars vous êtes chouette plus tard quand
vous dirait j'étais à waterloo compte en
fait pas un impôt tu étais le plus
grandes telles plus fort au merde c'est
peut-être la nappe ou quoi surprendre at
on aille aux riches et bien on
cordonnier wagram mais le tour d'europe
pour moi c'est râpé maintenant c'est
plus car accroché mon vélo dans toutes
présentes
tu peux vraiment accroché oui
définitivement
alors passez mathon bidon
et
et aurélie que dj mais ça la belle
avance au maire un gars doux mme avec
toi thaksin mais frissonne fonds minutes
sommes pas taire et chrosomes de quoi me
répéte ou aux hommes répètes harry
knowles est générée par un pétard est
nommé des femmes obtenaient gain
démissionner mme de conduire arrêt par
piston hamou dans une pochette homme
surprise sommes toi ma terreur et la
boucle aramin une injuste et sans du set
jusque hautement pomme dans les méchants
aux provocations m
ah ouais mon plateau mme obou jeunes bon
bout jeune robot jeunes refusent arrêt
avant sa mort fut zaré cherche homme là
bas comme on tue anus fumeuse ça du
belge um du belge en deux jours
insultant trois hommes pianu ce vade
retro satanas avait mon boutiste
pare-choc ou chercham la dinde aux roms
notre âme dans l'art dom nous mettons du
sport ont dû fatigue aime pas les
oreilles ils mériteraient prise sommes
venus de ce qu'ils nomment appel à
répliquer aux flics parfaitement de ce
fait la réflexion flemme des maladies
plus comme flic comme justice bannissent
à somain belmondo - fli comme agente us
centurio name et la rn13 discussio name
quoi s'est passé et nous allons tous
témoigné way imbéciles à m'enfoncer mme
marchot comme un conte du juge comme un
manche en faisons mec fremm
mais bush m l'arrière son gros 20 drôme
intentionnelle repetto revanche on avait
tous romane room rachat mais je révise
la prostate
sinon c'est la mousse commençâmes rue
larrey constate end et gras tome a enflé
room attentionnel dans les bains est
fluide comme plantu seraient pas tenues
papier rom papy rom bat et rom mais j'ai
eu des signes sommes pas pire au hms
khartoum grise m khartoum est grise m
voilà vignes et us vignes et us ligne et
tu joues à l'aube un thé stationner
m'assurant sam stationner mais c'est
pêchu amont minutes elle cherche homme
curriculum vitae voient la meute opus le
paquet us la mine raglan donne une règle
ou vignettes ont péri même où plusieurs
plaignants assurent ensemble dans la
8ème forum panarabe contraventionnelle
contraventionnelle votre avance à l'om
c'est la meilleurs mba merdum dit chez
merdum heisbourg dame quidditch et
bardos berthou merdum merde merde ou mr
toma sultane police elle n'est pas père
police m permet salariés rome avec une
gardienne us patcher explique johann
commissariat
rigolade enfants du soleil un long
métrage après la réplique à melun sénart
et posthume paulissen minute m
mais plaindre en préfecture paulissen
fonus suis des corps aime les jolies bus
de l'om
stendhal home in partibus à rigaud la
mapei ya réfléchi comme piqué flic amf
lé terme devenu 5000 balises dans le
foin de mer dom croisade
voilà c'est petit hommage ainsi averti
pendant longtemps on a vu ça vient vite
avec les journaux ne cessent de parler
d'une ville qui est en passe de détrôner
las vegas 2 2
battre tous les records de popularité
c'est nanterre en terre est une ville
admirable visiter nantais sa faculté
duato va y avoir des panneaux sur les
routes quand on arrivera à nanterre en
visitera ça comme provins la cité
médiévale et on parle surtout beaucoup
de nanterre parce que bien sûr il ya des
frottements à l'université yale et fois
comment les facultés et on parle surtout
énormément de des appariteurs muscler
ses les appariteurs musclés sont les
braves gens qui ont été engagées pour
ramener un peu de calme lorsqu'il est
étudiant est un peu excité un peu énervé
dont on ne sait pas exactement ce que
c'est que ces appariteurs musclé et nous
en avons 1 dans le studio qui a bien
voulu venir ici on peut pas dire que
vous soyez le shass des appariteurs
musquin parce qu'une association qui
n'apportent chef assumions vous vous
arrangez entre vous c'est un c'est un
groupement créé un roulement bien je
dois dire que vous êtes quand même
appariteurs musclé titularisé et vous
vous appelez gabriel ghislaine je peux
vous appeler diaby et coûtera moins cher
gaby dont le poser des petites questions
quand même sur son ca paritaire musclé
d'abord vous êtes là pour ramener le
calme
bon d'accord mais comment est-ce qu'on
vous recrutent comment est ce que vous
êtes engagés et bien c'est très simple
on recrute les appariteurs musclées
parmi les culturistes les athlètes les
danseurs mondains les antiquaires voyez
tous mais tous les gens qui sont musclés
je veux dire musclé pas naturellement
qu'ils ont un peu forcé sur le museau
lieu qui enfin si on travaille et les
pois les alter à l'aller l'inter les
pois les choses comme ça oui voilà alors
ben problème du recrutement est résolu
quand vous êtes
eh bien on est on est on est cinq très
exactement 5 5 pour toutes vos facultés
et cela c'est sa 5
je peux vous donnez les nous il ya jean
chrétien katchou oui il y a bambi je les
connais celui qui passait chez nous tu
dans le coeur il était chez le gris qui
chantait je suis né alors il est venu à
paris pour nice 1 et il ya sucre est
aussi secrète sucre c'est un il est
assez costaud lien secret toujours eut
modifié
et puis il y en a il y en a un autre là
mais qui n'est pas acquis c'est un
appariteur aussi mais enfin il était
appariteurs avant qu'on arrive c'est un
type qui s'appelle monsieur marche pied
c'est pas un prof de gym à juliette un
ancien hippie les patchs et vous classez
pour fait pas partie dans le disons le
carrément il fait pas partie de l'accord
atteint film est l'année de la cua voilà
c'était il y fait pas partie des ailes à
il en est pas bien et en inde et des
appariteurs maintenant imaginez qui est
je ne veux produire une révolte mais un
peu d'excitation à nanterre comment
est-ce que vous opérez qu'est ce que
vous faites vous l'efsf les étudiants se
mettent en colère riches a vu qu'on a
chacun en dessous des locaux donnez nous
des locaux bas vous arrivez alors on a
chacun sa méthode
oui on est chacun sa maison de motards
et j'ai la mienne je je repère le meneur
je repère oui un des meneurs quoi
surtout si le meneur il est gay trans il
est blond cinéma ce jeu leurs terres si
vous êtes un parfum jeu dur et louis
saha la festa et aux normes légales or
jaune repères je m'approche tout
doucement quand j'entends vie dont je
fus un coup de pied mais ça marche
puisque le programme
je suis là je ne joue pas alors je leur
père je m'avance et crac jeu cela tire à
walfadjri mobilise une sorte de luth
beef des fois bah oui mais alors là je
les linges parce que oui parce que vous
n'êtes pas mes changements pour amener
wydad oui je vais vous dire c'est un peu
la trouille
oui d'accord bombe écoutez je vous
remercie mon cher gaby je présente
inverse au revoir on va d'abord voir
l'écran quand vous pourrissent nous
allons nous tourner maintenant vers un
autre invité
qui nous fait là